OK, so let's really dig into
something big today, July 1st,
2025.
It's a pretty monumental day and
honestly a bit unsettling.
USAI, you know, America's
biggest humanitarian arm, has
officially shuttered its doors
after 63 years.
Yeah, it's huge.
And this isn't just like an
agency closing down.
It feels more like pulling back
the curtain on this whole
complex system of foreign aid,
this thing people sometimes call
America's soft empire.
Exactly.
And the consequences, I mean the
implications for millions of
people worldwide, they just
staggering.
And what's really fascinating,
or maybe revealing, is how this
whole thing forces us to look at
a paradox that's been there a
long time.
Our mission today really is to
unpack this idea that, well,
when it comes to foreign aid,
we've maybe always been living
on borrowed time.
A borrowed time?
Yeah.
So this deep dive, we'll explore
why this lifeline, why it was
never really permanent, what it
actually cost, you know, beyond
the dollars, and what happens
now when the lender, so to
speak, decides to call in the
debt.
And you can't ignore the
immediate shock of it all.
The Lancet, I mean, that's a top
medical journal.
They're predicting this closure
could cost up to 14,000,000
lives by 2030. 14,000,000.
Yeah, it breaks down to what, An
average of 88 deaths an hour?
And a third of those are kids
under 5.
Yeah, those are the raw facts.
Really sets the stage.
It absolutely does, and it feeds
right into that core metaphor
you mentioned Borrowed time.
Exactly.
Yeah, that's the central idea
here.
Foreign aid, it is often
presented, you know, as this
promise, freedom, prosperity.
But there's always this hidden
threat, this sort of fine print.
The promise can be withdrawn.
It's not really a gift.
Our sources suggest it's much
more like a lease.
A lease.
That's quite a way to put it.
A moral lease, you said.
What does that imply?
Like what happens if the tenant
defaults or the landlord just
changes their mind?
Precisely.
The sources use that term moral
leasehold.
It suggests this power dynamic,
right where the aid recipient,
but it might be building things,
improving lives, but they never
truly owned the foundation.
They're building on the support,
the help.
It's rented, it's not really
yours.
And that really frames the whole
thing as transactional.
Underneath it all, you're
essentially building on someone
else's land.
That's a stark image building on
rented ground.
But let's rewind a bit.
Was it always like this, this
lease model?
What was the original idea
behind USAID?
Back in 61, Kennedy pitched it
as this.
This noble thing, right?
A moral obligation.
Oh, he definitely framed it that
way, but it was always sort of
dual natured.
Right from the start.
Kennedy was smart.
He talked about moral
obligation, and I think there
was genuine humanitarian impulse
there, for sure.
But at the same time, it was
also a very shrewd geopolitical
move, a necessity.
Well, it bought friends.
It opened up markets, it created
buffer states against communism.
Very pragmatic, really.
So it was both things at once, A
rescue mission.
And also, like our sources put
it, a kind of Trojan horse aid
that gets you compliance or
leverage.
That's the idea.
How did it work on the ground?
Well, the sources say it was
designed to keep boots polished
and Halos clean.
Basically, you could be seen
doing good feeding the hungry,
which is genuinely good work,
right?
But while doing that, you're
also sort of inoculating markets
against your rivals, preventing
threats, stabilizing regions in
your favor, its influence
without, you know, sending in
the troops.
Clever.
And that approach, that
strategy, it really hit a high
point, didn't it, with George W
Bush's PEPFAR program, the
President's Emergency Plan for
AIDS Relief starting around
2003.
That was huge.
Saved millions from AIDS,
especially in Africa.
Absolutely.
PEPFAR is often seen as like the
peak of American soft power in
action.
Yeah, an undeniable public
health success.
But our sources call even that a
civilizational bargain.
What's meant by that?
How is it different from, say,
earlier aid?
Well, even this, you know, this
gold standard of targeted aid,
it's described as that bargain,
because it wasn't just pure
altruism, it was still deeply
transactional.
The underlying message, may be
unspoken but clear, was
something like We help you
survive this crisis, you align
with us, we keep you alive, you
stay in our sphere of influence.
Our sources really highlight
this as the soft empire in its
best, most honest form.
A powerful, if implicit, deal.
A deal, A pact.
But what happens when that pact,
that lifeline, starts feeling,
well, more like a leash?
This is where it gets tricky.
You almost hear Reagan's ghost,
right?
I'm from the government and I'm
here to help.
Yeah, that quote just hangs over
this whole discussion, doesn't
it?
Because the help as a source of
stress again and again, it's
never really unconditional.
Relief isn't meant to be a
permanent foundation.
It's more like a bandage.
A bandage, Yeah, Buys you time.
Time for a wound.
You're sort of expected to heal
yourself eventually, so.
What are the dangers then, when
that bandage of A just stays on
becomes permanent?
How does it freeze political
risk, like the sources say, or
undermine local efforts?
Well, the big one is dependency
aid saves lives absolutely in
the short term, but it can also
unintentionally freeze things.
It can prop up weak states or
leaders who maybe wouldn't
survive otherwise, reducing the
pressure for them to reform.
And it can undercut local
agency.
If people get used to external
help solving problems, it can
dampen local initiative, local
solutions.
You start expecting someone else
to feed you next time, which
ironically makes you more
vulnerable if that aid suddenly
disappears.
That makes sense.
It's a difficult dynamic, and
our sources mentioned Bono's
farewell to USAID workers.
He apparently got quite
emotional, said something like
they called you crooks when you
were the best of us.
You can understand the sentiment
seeing the human side.
Oh absolutely, you can feel the
grief there.
Many people USA were incredibly
dedicated.
But there's a counterpoint in
the sources too.
Isn't there a kind of challenge
to that?
Yes, a really crucial one.
While acknowledging the
dedication and the grief, the
sources posed this question.
OK, but who built the dependency
that allows crooks to exploit
the system in the 1st place?
Who kept the soft power flowing,
sometimes in ways that actually
weaken the local capacity?
Aid, even with the best
intentions, can sometimes feed
corruption, empower elites who
capture the benefits right.
So sometimes maybe the best of
us end up being well meaning
cogs in a system that
perpetuates problems even as it
solves others.
Which brings us right back to
today, to the foreclosure,
essentially the 2025 closure
under Trump 2 point O, fueled by
this isolationist populism.
And then Elon Musk comes in as
this czar of government
efficiency.
Yeah.
Reportedly calling USAID corrupt
and putting it through the wood
chipper.
That's the language used.
Wow.
And this really is the moment
that moral leasehold we talked
about it just expires.
Can put the sources point to the
cold calculation.
From a republic's viewpoint,
that soft empire Moat cost
Americans about $0.17 a day.
Not a huge amount individually,
but.
But voters got tired.
Taxpayers decided they wanted
the defenses, the Moat inside
the walls, not projected outer.
It's a fundamental shift from
global engagement back to
focusing inward.
OK, so let's get to the really
tough questions this raises.
The analogies are sources use
are quite powerful.
One compares relief aid to AIDS
medication.
Can you unpack that?
Yeah, it's a really critical,
maybe unsettling analogy.
Relief aid, like ART, the
antiretroviral therapy for HIV,
it operates on a similar
paradox.
Once you start it, you create a
dependency.
The body or the system relies on
it.
If you suddenly pull that
support, the patient or the
guest case, the independent
system can crash, sometimes even
worse than if they'd never had
the help.
So it's chronic care, not a
cure.
Exactly.
It manages symptoms, keeps
things going, but it doesn't
necessarily fix the underlying
vulnerability.
That's a really stark way to
think about it.
It forces you to reconsider,
consider what help even means
long term.
And it leads to this just raw
moral question the sources posed
directly to you, the listener.
Would you rather drown alone or
live forever on borrowed time
with a leash tied to your next
meal?
Yeah.
And what about sovereignty?
I mean the sources asked what
kind of neighbor builds you a
house but keeps a kill switch
for the lights.
These are the core dilemmas,
aren't they?
But it's important we need to
bring in the nuance here to the
conflicting views.
There's what the source calls a
bullshit check, an argument
against just saying tough luck,
bootstrap or drown.
What's that argument it?
Basically says look that's cold
and it ignores how we got here.
It ignores history, colonialism,
Cold War, proxy fights, propping
up puppet regimes.
All these things contributed to
making some states fragile in
the 1st place.
You can't just expect them to
magically become strong
overnight, especially if their
foundations were messed with for
decades.
That's.
A fairpoint acknowledging the
history, right?
And on the flip side, revisiting
Bono's point is teary fears are
real.
The human cost is real.
But there's also the perspective
that aid bureaucracies can
become self-sustaining entities.
They feed contractors, build
careers, maybe benefit local
elites as much as the needy.
So the system itself develops
interests.
Exactly.
So sometimes the best of us, as
the source puts it, might just
be well meaning middle men
tangled up in a very complex,
sometimes self-serving system.
So where does that leave
America's perspective in all
this?
What the core take away seems to
be that the whole soft power
myth was always half cover a way
to project influence nicely.
But when that influence isn't
seen as strategically vital
anymore, or it just gets too
expensive, well, the world's
margin kids get pushed off the
Ledger.
Wow, pushed off the Ledger.
Yeah, the moral lease runs out
the tenants on their own.
So wrapping this up, what's the
main message for us, for the
listener trying to process this
huge shift?
It sounds like the bottom line
is, well, relief is temporary.
That seems to be the strong
message coming through.
Relief should be a bridge, not
your bedrock.
Build on your own foundation,
your own stone.
Because otherwise.
Or you'll drown when the flood
comes.
It's a challenging thought, and
the sources leave us with this
final provocation.
Something for you listening to
really chew on.
If you build your children's
survival on the grace of
strangers, you can't rage when
the grace expires.
If you think the Empire's help
is a blank check, you just
haven't been reading History A.
Sobering reminder.
And maybe the final thought is
when that flood comes, you can't
really blame the empire that
told you over and over I'm from
the government and I'm here to
help.
Until I'm not.